ciao a tutti sono tremila barisani sono
una bresciana
ho vissuto a brescia finché e ha avuto
all'età del liceo poi sono andata a
vivere a milano e dopo aver fatto tanti
lavori compreso o lavorare in un
villaggio turistico sul lago di garda a
un certo punto ho deciso che volevo
provare a fare la scrittrice rho molto
grande e avevo quasi 40 anni perché
pensavo che quella fosse veramente la
mia strada però pensavo non sapevo una
prova ci prova e può andare incontro
agli alimenti infatti non l'ho detto a
nessuno perché la figura del fallito del
velleitario era proprio quella che non
volevo fare insomma ho scritto questo
romanzo che schierava il plagio
l'ho mandato a una casa editrice anzi a
due case editrici e tutte e due l'hanno
prendono ormai avevo già detto di sì
alla prima che era a casa editrice
mondadori e così eccomi a 39 anni
quaranta esordire come scrittrice tutta
la mia vita è passata tra milano e roma
facendo la scrittrice insegnando ai
corsi di scrittura creativa
scrivendo per la radio scrivendo
qualcosa per la televisione anche un
programma ho scritto per la rai per
sugli scrittori italiani nelle loro zone
nei loro luoghi
insomma la mia vita da scrittrice era
piena era bella ne avevo già abbastanza
finché a un certo punto mi hanno
chiamata da brescia il sindaco di
brescia chiedendomi di tornare in quella
che era la mia città ma io l'avevo
completamente abbandonata per fare il
presidente e la presidente del teatro di
brescia che un trick cioè uno dei teatri
di rilevante interesse culturali secondo
la definizione del ministero dei beni
culturali quindi abbiamo dei
finanziamenti pubblici
abbiamo pubblico e abbiamo anche un
obbligo che è quello di fare teatro di
qualità insomma non è teatro di
intrattenimento e basta di cassetta ma
anche un teatro che sia utile alla
cittadinanza utile nel senso che fa
crescere sia culturalmente sia anche
come cittadini
ebbene
io non mi ero mai occupata di teatro
accettato questo incarico sono tornata a
brescia ho cominciato a rick a minare
per brescia che era la mia città che
avevo completamente perduto nel anche
nella memoria non mi ricordavo più i
nomi nelle vie delle piazze era da tanto
tempo che mancava
fate conto che adesso a 60 anni sono
presidente di questo teatro da quattro
anni e me ne ero andata a 18 pensate
quanto tempo non avevo passato in questa
città le città piccole cambiano poco e
capisco perché i narratori le usano come
sfondo per esempio per le serie di
gialli perché sono delle quinte perfette
tutti si conoscono e ci incontri
qualcuno che ti saluta che i noti che la
mattina ha rivestito in un modo e la
sera in un altro e chi avrà visto che
avrà incontrato insomma per le trame dei
gialli le città piccole sono perfette e
cosa mi ha dato a brescia intanto vabbè
tornare alle radici il tema del ritorno
alle radici se ci pensate è uno dei
grandi temi della narrativa uno dei miei
scrittori preferiti che li pronto ha
scritto i suoi romanzi più belli secondo
me proprio patrimonio a uno di questi o
anche teatro di sabato proprio
tornando al fatto alla domanda che tutti
ci facciamo a un certo punto ma chi sono
da dove vengo perché quando sei giovane
la prima cosa che vuoi fare è la fuga
per me scrivere andare a milano andare a
roma è stata la fuga e poi chi viene
invece il desiderio di tornare sulle tue
orme poi ho fatto anche delle
riflessioni
su il teatro e sul mio mestiere che la
scrittura io anzitutto non credo nel
romanzo storico cioè per lo meno non è
nelle mie cose
lei piace che la narrativa e così teatro
raccontino la realtà penso che siano dei
formidabili mezzi per ampliare la
conoscenza di chi legge e vi chiama
teatro sui problemi della propria
contemporaneità e anche per i nostri
successori quelli che speriamo ci
leggeranno quando non ci saremo più
andranno a teatro a vedere delle
rappresentazioni
che gi ambientati in questo periodo sono
anche o una forma di studio io per
esempio ho imparato molto di più sulla
storia francese
leggendo i romanzi di balzac la comédie
humaine che
negli esami di storie sono anche
laureata in storia tra l'altro quindi
diciamo che penso che la narrativa e il
teatro nel teatro poi in particolare
perché unisce alla fabulazione alla
narrazione anche la rappresentazione del
vivo quindi ha la capacità di fissare
nella memoria in un modo particolarmente
emotivo i suoi contenuti ecco è stato
una cosa che stiamo facendo e che
debutta proprio questa sera è
portare i miti attualizzandoli
apprendiamo tremiti pilota
eracle e medea uno può pensare che noi
ancora sti miti cosa cosa vogliono dire
cosa ci rappresentano oggi ecco sono
stati attualizzati per esempio medea
forse molti di voi lo sanno
era una straniera era una donna
abbastanza infelice era lontana da casa
era vista con sospetto perché non era
una donna del ecco l'idea in via milano
la nostra medea è una donna un'immigrata
che arriva in italia arriva in italia si
innamora di un uomo che non è un
brav'uomo e ci fa anche due figli e lo
deve mantenere facendo la prostituta
finché a un certo punto perde la testa e
va come sappiamo filottete invece nel
mito e un uomo abbandonato da ulisse
perché ha una gamba ferita e
maleodorante su un'isola sull'isola di
lesmo nel nostro mito raccontato oggi è
un povero vecchio abbandonato in una rsa
sappiamo è un problema grave importante
della contemporaneità non è che la gente
tutta cattiva ma è che molti devono
lavorare non hanno tempo per
guardare i loro vecchi per assisterli
come si faceva una volta non so mi
chiamo nelle piscine padane dove
vivevano tante famiglie e ci si dava il
cambio nel curare i bambini e nello
spazio dei vecchi e poi c'era chi è che
invece di essere l'eroe forze che
supporta tutte le fatiche che mi fanno
provare per mettere alla prova la sua
forza è un povero padre di famiglia
separato una macchina da soldi deve solo
pagare pagare pagare pagare alimenti è
visto solo in questo modo e sprofonda
nella depressione ecco questo è un modo
di rendere il mito farlo conoscere
perché le persone che verrà nostra ad
assistere sicuramente avranno qualche
nozione su questi uniti se dopo aver
visto lo spettacolo e in più di
rappresentare i problemi della
quotidianità che sono tanti e qui e
penso che la funzione della scrittura e
del teatro e lo faccio anch'io scrivendo
si sa raccontare cosa ci sta succedendo
adesso anche perché siamo di fronte a
una rivoluzione a un cambio di paradigma
come non c'era amministrato se pensiamo
al ci sono state le guerre e con le
guerre mondiali noi oggi le guerre
mondiali ne abbiamo le guerre le abbiamo
allontanate dai confini europei è la
nostra guerra e il cancro e co lead
queste sono le guerre che viviamo
però c'è un'altra guerra di cui non si
parla che è la guerra della
globalizzazione è la guerra
diciamo dell'economia fluida e la
civiltà analogica che e di libertà
digitale ecco tutto questo cambio di
paradigma che rende le nostre vite
sempre più insicure sempre più in balia
di eventi che nessuno può governare non
è poco per fare una statua simbolo non
può governanti cittadino men che meno ma
neanche la politica perché sono gli
elementi trasnazionali e poi il
riconoscimento delle libertà dei diritti
che per anni decenni per secoli non c'e
stato tutto questo alla civiltà dei
diritti e della rivendicazione dei
diritti secondo me aveva raccontato va
portato a tutti perché facciamo fa parte
della nostra civiltà e questo è il
compito poi dello scrittore del
drammaturgo dell'attore e regista di noi
che facciamo questo mestiere di
diffusione culturale
naturalmente per un cittadino di milano
o di roma è forse più facile o di new
york figuriamoci
vivere questi temi questa quotidianità
nelle città più piccole arriva sempre un
po più tardi con un minimo di scarto che
può essere un bene perché non si
rincorrono le mode più scelte che sei
mesi dopo sono già passate e a volte
invece è bello a dare un'apertura
portando quello che viene da fuori anche
in città come brescia e io come
scrittrice ho imparato molto da questa
esperienza moltissimo sto imparando e
e riflessione perché soprattutto un
mestiere come il mio penso tutti i
mestieri poi in realtà è un mestiere che
mi porta a osservare le persone
chiedermi chi sono a guardare l'altro
lato della medaglia come diceva di
slanci posca il compito del poetica
dello scrittore diciamo di chi fa
cultura e raccontare girare la medaglia
e raccontare l'altro lato che non sono
quello che si vuole il compito dello
scrittore del drammaturgo e cercare
appunto quell altro lato della medaglia
è la cosa che non si vede nelle migliaia
di immagini il dettaglio che magari si
perde nella visione di questi colori
questi insieme e noi dobbiamo andare a
scavare cercarlo e fanno vedere allo
spettatore e al lettore